open oven take out my crust pour caramel
over my crust
yeah
yeah and this is another episode of
Boston translation why am I dressed up
as an egg because it is a very special
Halloween episode
as always we take a recipe we put into
Google translate it goes from English to
Korean to Sudanese and many many more
until finally back to English to give us
this hilariously translated recipe does
anyone think Jasmine is getting too good
at this yes me too so today I have her
facing off against a professional pastry
chef will her experience as a
professional pastry chef give her the
leg up or will Jasmine's translation
expertise get her the win let's find out
you go okay thank you also you guys
might notice that Kelly's not here today
we got a surprise call from her
yesterday and she's having her baby
baby all the love to you if you want to
spread the love to her put it in the
comments below we wish her the page
family all the best we made
it let's do it
a scary bike
how do you eat a bike I don't know this
is just too much to process for food
step number one step one 350 fire in the
oven I know that one preheat the oven to
350. so I think 350 fire in the oven can
only mean preheat the oven to 350. I'll
be right back I'm gonna go do that
flower tip put two cups of Sandwich
flour in a meat grinder until smooth add
four tablespoon of oil and stir put two
cups of I would assume all-purpose flour
bread flour I'm just gonna go with
regular flour I'm really scared going up
against a pastry chef today I might hop
on this scary bacon right away bread
flour all-purpose flour and cake flour
cake flour
four tablespoons of oil I feel like
that's actually butter unsalted butter
maybe so I think meat grinder means
blender in a meat grinder until smooth
I'm gonna add two cups of Sandwich flour
to my meat grinder here and I'm getting
it really nice and smooth confidence
level currently is at a three we'll
build it we'll build it I think right
now we're making a pie dough add four
tablespoons of oil which I think is
better stir four tablespoons of oil and
stir butter but I feel like it's oil I
do feel like it's oil I'll do canola
four tablespoons though this doesn't
feel right well I've certainly stirred
and now it is resisting given how I feel
a hint at this moment is quite necessary
and I want it from memo and memo is
going to
dry
wow this is quite good
a lamp shelf oh it's a person it's you
it's butter
this is the second Masterpiece from Lost
in Translation season two comment below
why you deserve this art piece and we
will send it to you personally signed
because Katie says I can't undo this
step I'm just gonna have to move forward
with my oily flower when I make pies I
use cold butter and I pulse it in a food
processor stir
I think that's good let's see what's
next step number three pour batter into
eight cake pan I have no batter click
below and go towards the activity tray
transfer the pie crust into a baking
dish and push against those sides eight
cake pan this is not cake pie pan that
looks like it might be eight inches it's
not a pie pan but it's a tart pan click
below and go towards the activity tray I
do not know what that could mean you
know what we're just gonna we're just
gonna flour this a little bit pour
batter this is not ready oh tart I have
a feeling that it's going to be the tart
pan and I'm going towards the activity
tray which means adding it to my baking
dish here and I'm pushing it against the
edges of the dish I think I need to stop
and take a hint hit box let's do mimo
sing it
you've made your batter it's made of
flour so go go ahead and use your batter
at the end
[Music]
this looks good even though it's the
most oily pie crust I've ever made I am
putting holes in the crust so it has
some room to breathe click click you use
your fingers right click click push it
into the pan knead this into a dough
this feels like it's not coming together
like it would be a pie dough
step number four add the mixture to the
flavor and leave it for 12 minutes
remove a wire rack to cool okay so I
think this is my mixture the flavor is
the oven and we're going to cook for 12
minutes and then afterwards we'll remove
it to a wire rack to cool I must have
missed something somewhere I need to put
water in here we're just gonna do that
until it becomes a dough before I had
every expectation of failing but now I'm
failing harder than I thought this is
embarrassing I swear I bake better than
this I will be right back
so we're going to roll this out we're
going to put it in there click below and
go towards the activity tray so I think
that means we should in the pan I'm just
take off the top since I decided that
this is a tart we're just gonna dock it
we're gonna bake it for 12 minutes now
step number five mix a quarter cup water
and one cup sugar in a small bowl leave
on the fire so it does not dissolve they
are placed in the electrified syrup for
10 minutes I feel like this makes more
sense to me we're mixing one cup sugar
and a cup of quarter cup of water leave
on fire which could mean the stove are
we making caramel saucepan I'm gonna add
a quarter cup water sugar I think is
just granulated sugar so a cup of that
leave on the fire so it does not
dissolve I think although contradicting
itself I do think it's stir until
dissolve you're not supposed to stir
water and sugar but I'm just getting the
lump of it gone I don't want to touch it
because then it'll crystallize so you
kind of have to let sugar and water do
its thing step number six as soon as the
sugar is completely dissolved
immediately add half cup of flour and
mix carefully pour in half cup of the
cream all at once I don't like this
anymore oh my my okie dokie cream I
think is heavy cream flour I think might
be flour why would you add
flour I really think being a pastry chef
is hindering my ability to process this
smelling this step has made me realize
we're probably making caramel so for
immediately add half cup of flour I
think it's to add half a cup of caramels
first my half cup cream I've chosen
heavy whipping cream I've added my cream
now I'm going to remove it from the heat
I'm going to use the residual heat to
melt down my caramels so now I am going
to mix I need a hint so I'm picking
Katie
oh my God
as oil and sometimes it's wrapped in
foil
butter
so I got my butter sugar and water is
electrified Butter's melted and then
we're gonna put cream
next up while I stir step seven remove
the pan from the oven and stir in red
salt is blood oh
okay wait wait wait wait no no no so
remove the pan from the oven which is
the pie pan Which has been baking I'm
removing pan from heat and I'm gonna
stir in red food coloring sure take a
look red salt is blood which I know has
to be caramel now this is a red blood
and I'm gonna put this in the tart pan
oh my gosh is it hot tamales
I think red salt is red food coloring
and this will be our blood I'm just
going to add until I think it's blood
colored so I think stir is poor caramel
is blood while I stir I'm going to move
on to the next step step 8 sprinkle
blood candy on biscuits are the end and
put in the freezer if you want if you
want do I want I'm just gonna see what
we have it could be anything oh it's my
Biscuit My tart crust cherry black
licorice is pretty scary I love black
licorice what is red that you can
sprinkle wait I think it might be
shortbread on a shortbread crust
um
uh I find myself a little puzzled
so I think it calls for the hint box the
hint box all right Katie I would like
you to
[Music]
dip open oven take out my crust pour
caramel over my crust
yeah
Hot Tamales you know what I'm I think
it's hot tamales I don't know why it's
red it's candy none of this makes sense
it's gonna look like a bicycle wheel I
don't think bike is bike but I'm making
it bike so now I'm sprinkling my blood
candy all in oh yeah this looks good
since I want to I am going to put this
in the freezer do I want to I think I do
to cool it down and let it set so we're
gonna put it in the freezer an
undetermined amount of time we're just
gonna say like 30 minutes step number
nine tato ice chocolate six ounces
chocolate and a half bat butter in a
bowl half bat half cup half stick of
butter this is a bat why is that a bat
bat
baseball
stick baseball bat stick half stick
butter and then we need six ounces of
chocolate this is a nice medium
semi-sweet chocolate chocolate but what
kind of chocolate ooh dark semi-sweet I
think that would be semi-sweet chocolate
chips I'm gonna do half a bat of butter
six ounces I'm gonna cut this in half
cut it down step number ten heat a small
saucepan over medium heat or pour in 2 3
cup cream until it favors what do you
mean or fevers probably means it gets
really hot so I'm gonna get a small
saucepan we're making ganache this could
only be ganache all right so I think 2 3
cup cream is 2 3 cup heavy whipping
cream into the saucepan it goes I'm just
gonna put this on the heat until it
comes to a simmer so I'm just heating
the 2 3 cup of cream until it favors so
I'm just gonna wait till this gets
steamy step number 11 pour the hot oil
into a bowl with the chocolate let's
stand for five minutes then stir until
smooth shiny and smooth again I love
that okay so I think this is my hot oil
and I'm gonna pour this over my butter
and chocolate and let it sit pour the
hot oil which is the hot cream it just
means to let it melt we're gonna cover
it five minutes then we're gonna stir
I'm just gonna cover this up so it melts
a little faster I'm a huge chocolate fan
the fact that this is chocolate and
caramel I am stoked I think I'm making
some sort of ganache so it has to be
like double smooth all right let's move
on to the next step step 12 top the
ganache is the name with caramel shells
and spread evenly ice for 10 minutes
this guy here ganache is his name I'm
gonna go get my blood pie I'm gonna pour
this on top of it which is the caramel
shells spread it evenly and then back to
the freezer for 10 minutes we top the
ganache over the caramel shell which is
the tart spread it evenly ice has to
mean chill we're gonna put that in the
refrigerator and show it ice for 10
minutes step number 13 make the web page
place two cups this is foam in a large
bowl for the microwave and cook for 20
to 40 seconds to soften the balls
stirring occasionally this is gonna be
fun we're making
marshmallows we're making marshmallows
oh this has to be marshmallows because
they're foamy well is there anything
there that's like foamy I don't like
want to look because I have to like my
gut mini marshmallows big marshmallows
Cool Whip jet puff I mean these are
foamy I've never microwaved marshmallow
but I've always wanted to so I think for
that reason alone we've got to do that I
think Heather definitely chose
marshmallows and I have a feeling
Heather is really nailing this
We're not gonna make it now I'm going to
soften these balls in the microwave in
20 to 40 second intervals so now we're
going to microwave this for 20 30
seconds step number 14 let the margarine
stand for a few minutes then lift it
press it and rub it with your fingers
creating a fluffy effect
they put it on the author margarine so I
think this is my margarine I'm gonna let
it stand for a few minutes to cool
slightly I need a hint and I'm gonna get
it from Nemo
yes it is a bowl and then you're mixing
and you're pulling
spreading oh we're stretching it we're
stretching overhead let's create a
fluffy effect lift it press it rub it
wow that looks so good this is perfect
keep my hands cold oh this is
very weird but satisfying I've never
done anything like this before but this
is quite fun if this is wrong I don't
want to be right oh
this is a lot Messier actually than I
thought it was going to be but this
works and I'm now gonna go wash my hands
[Laughter]
the arachnid sprinkle the black licorice
slices with the sliced Licorice and stir
in the sliced licorice stir in the
onions and stir in the onions there's a
lot of Licorice and onions in this so
I'm gonna be making a spider it's
clearly a spider sprinkle the black
licorice slices I do feel like I saw
some licorice black licorice yeah onions
garlic garlic bulb bulb ball Whoppers
Whoppers maybe Whoppers with like little
legs coming out so sprinkling has to be
just placing stir in the onions no no
onions in this stir we can say cut we're
gonna cut little legs I think this is
licorice number one and licorice number
two and I think sliced licorice is these
legs I must cut them into little legs we
got an arachnid there's my two spiders
I've never had black licorice before
what wait you've never had black
licorice what
oh no why does it taste like medicine
step number 16 almond paste with
chocolate to cover the body and send the
chocolate to the head so that the stars
are scattered in the center excuse me I
thought I made the body
but it's not good enough I see almond
paste to cover the body I actually think
this means to like add just a little dot
to the body there's also raisins oh
maybe the raisin I'm not putting raisins
in my dessert that's ridiculous oh there
is sprinkles oh chocolate covered
almonds make sense for the body because
I don't have to mold anything I do think
the second half is to sprinkle on some
sprinkles all right it's happening oh
it's cute
and then the stars are scattered in the
center sprinkles we're going to go back
to these guys today I'm putting
chocolate chips on the body because
these are the stars scattered in the
center I am on the last line explore and
enjoy I'm gonna plate it I think that
means you're done we're gonna pull it
out of the pan it looks like a cheesy
pizza
he's a zombie explore and enjoy explore
and enjoy oh I am done so curious to see
what Heather's looks like
you did it I did it and that was really
stressful I'm excited to see what you
made let's bring our dishes out before
we see the original dish oh God I really
want to know what you chose for foamy
balls
and open your eyes
oh oh
yours is bleeding wow well I'm happy we
did the marshmallow thing similar yeah I
was very nervous about that and it was
quite messy did you use the bowl of ice
water underneath
no did you you did phenomenal and I
would definitely hire you wow thank you
shall we bring out the original dish oh
yeah oh my God
what is this called we called a spooky
spider so where did you find this recipe
we were inspired by some things online
but Nemo actually told us about the
marshmallow web thing so let's try each
other and then we'll try the original
dish I like the blood look nice and gory
I think we should try yours first for
sure
it's Ultra caramel now can we try yours
if we have to
wait yes yes
a little texture spicy it's a fun
surprise we've tried them both shall we
try the original recipe oh yeah oh
there's red inside
wow cheers
so smooth proper that ganache I did Chad
what no I think overall we did really
good look how similar these are they are
similar though yeah all right guys
thanks so much for watching Heather
thank you so much for joining us on this
special Halloween episode and everyone
make sure to tune in next week because
we have an exciting season finale see ya
[Music]
can I have a meditation break meditation
you haven't even looked at it I need
Kelly singing she's too busy screaming
right now welcome back we should name
our hot plate Hot Plate Pete
[Music]